le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ces
dernières années cyril lignac pourra
autant fait parler pour sa vie privée
que pour ces sucreries
s'il est l'un des chefs les plus
reconnus il est aussi l'un des plus
présent à la télévision et cette
présence a un coût celui d'intrigués sur
sa vie privée
sans compter que le jeune homme a connu
une vie sentimentale pour le moins
intense et pleine de paillettes dans le
passé il a été en couple avec la très
médiatique sophie marceau jusqu'en 2016
puis avec mélanie doutey autre
comédienne reconnue avant finalement de
tomber dans les bras de marine une jeune
inconnue de 31 ans
mais aujourd'hui d'après le magazine
voici c'est une nouvelle femme qui
semble avoir fait chavirer le coeur du
cuisiné rencontré cette année lors de
ses vacances à saint tropez deborah 41
ans semble être un amour de vacances qui
se prolongent régulièrement cyril lignac
fait des allers retours depuis paris
pour la rejoindre dans le sud où elle
vit sur les clichés des amoureux qui ont
circulé dans la presse on découvre
deborah mais aussi un cyril souriant et
plus chevelu que jamais avec sa nouvelle
coupe
bref visiblement l'amour fait pousser
des ailes et des cheveux aussi
[Applaudissements]
oui mais donc cyril lignac c'est un
playboy faire ne mettrait jamais
célibataire et il a toujours des
nouvelles moeurs et en plus ils
s'affichent constamment avec donc ça lui
plaît en fait ses choux cliff et
magazines people avec toujours une
nouvelle meuf et en plus apparemment son
ex-mari donc créé avec deux qu'ils
étaient très amoureux avec qui il est
resté deux ans l'ex femme
ouais nan que deux ans oui comment et ça
faisait à peine deux mois qu'ils
s'étaient séparés comme si vous alliez
son ex mari oui donc là il faisait émis
2 un four d'une pour série b pardon mais
pas à ça faisait à peine deux mois qu'il
était séparé que déjà il faisait la une
d'un nouveau magazine people
une nouvelle mode ici alors les
sélectionne il alors même
sentimentalement les mecs on sait tous
qu'il est mercotte arrêté c'est bon
assez bon oui c'est drôle ou non je
voulais dire et c'est bien qu'ils
sortent avec cette jeune fille marine
qu'on connaît pas parce qu'on dit d'elle
débord evora delà des bonnes marines et
son deuxième prénom je veux dire c'est
que il commençait à avoir une petite
réputation un petit peu moyenne dans la
presse people d'un drapeau ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement star fucker c'est à
dire que les mélanie les soucis sont là
et très beau sexuelle tiré par la
lumière
pardon à les poser et qu'on l'avait vu
poser avec ses chais de minibus ya
quelques années aussi il est il et voilà
on pensait qu'ils sont attirés par ce
qui brille et un petit peu la lumière
les jeux les voitures les jeux les
filles un peu tout ce qui était un petit
peu paillettes
donc là c'est bien que ce soit j'espère
qu'il va être un bilan de votre avenir
qui est intéressant c'est que la télé
est entré et enfin la télé a rendu
visible des chefs il ya eu un avant et
un après avant voyez pas un bocuse
robuchon dans public ou dans closer
alors que lui maintenant c'est devenu
des gens un peu avec un peu branché un
peu sexy un peu à la mode